United Nations highest court gave the
final word Thursday on a maritime
dispute that espirited Nicaragua against
Colombia for more than 20 years the
courts concluded that under customary
international law a state's entitlement
to a continental shelf Beyond 200
nautical miles from the baselines from
which the breadth of its territorial sea
is measured may not extend within 200
nautical miles from the baselines of
another state the ruling dismissed
Nicaragua's bid to gain economic rights
over an area of the Caribbean Sea that
has long been under the sovereignty of
Colombia Nicaragua had claimed its
seabed extended past the customary limit
of 200 nautical miles or 370 kilometers
Colombia's president Gustavo Petro said
the ruling was a great victory for his
country and hope it was the end of the
Border dispute a sentiment echoed by
Colombia's foreign minister
this ruling settles the matter in the
courts for good it's a victory that
favors every country and is based on
common sense it also implies the
protection of the environment of the
seaflower biosphere reserve and of the
oceanic biodiversity of our country
since the early 20th century Nicaragua
and Colombia disputed ownership of the
fish and oil-rich Waters of this part of
the Caribbean and Nicaragua's repeatedly
sued since 2001.
in 2012 the Central American country
gained fishing rights over a portion of
the region that Colombia's Navy has
continued to Patrol its Waters the
archipelago of the San Andreas in
Providencia island is physically much
closer to Nicaragua's Coast but has been
part of Colombia for a century
the leader of Nicaragua's delegation
said his country will closely study the
ruling but will comply with it obviously
it's a very complicated issue we have to
study the Judgment we have to study also
on the ground but it implies because it
has consequences in a very large and
complicated area so that has to be
studied but in principle obviously
whatever the court said Nicaragua would
comply with it I said that's always done
the ruling was received with Relief by
the residents of the San Andreas and
Providencia Island that have long feared
that a decision in favor of Nicaragua
would have disrupted their economic
activities and many observers also hope
it will help to defuse the long-lived
tensions between Colombia and Nicaragua
over this Precious part of sea
Alessandro Al Jazeera Bogota